what app people of the world of life I
hope you all had a good time watching
the Golden Globes I myself really didn't
get to watch a lot of the Golden Globes
because I was doing this video but the
time has come to reveal the you
reviewers movie awards nominations
officially the ballots were in there
tallied up here they are before we get
started people have asked me if I'm
gonna do an Oscar snubs video I'm not
going to just because I like being
positively proactive in a proactively
positive kind of way I would rather just
concentrate on the you reviewers movie
Awards and do our thing without further
ado and no other lectures here are the
nominations we're gonna start off with
best script for best script we have
silver linings playbook followed by Argo
then we have Seven Psychopaths followed
by Django Unchained and looper next
category is best trailer this is a
trailer that came out in 2012 for any
movie it could be for a movie that comes
out in 2021 but if the trailer came out
in 2012 it is all good and here we are
the best trailer nominees are Man of
Steel followed by looper followed by
Iron Man 3 then we have star trek into
darkness and then The Place Beyond The
Pines apparently avengers trailers are
Place Beyond The Pines that's
the one that really got the blood pump
alright moving on next category is best
animation and for best animation we have
ParaNorman followed by wreck-it Ralph
then we got the Pirates band of misfits
then we got brave and then finishing off
the list is Frankenweenie the next
category is best visual effects it's
funny because Michael Bay didn't make a
movie this year so it's like what are we
gonna do without dispersion what world
would we live in where we do the you
reviewers Movie Awards and Michael Bay
doesn't make a movie it looks like this
for Best Visual Effects we have
Prometheus followed by Life of Pi
followed by The Dark Knight Rises then
we got the Avengers killing it off in 48
frames a second is the Hobbit and
unexpected journey the next category is
one of my favorite categories I like
categories like this and that is most
underrated film this is the movie that
came out didn't really get the publicity
and hype that it should have gotten
there were quite a few of those in 2012
and we have the nominations and they are
Seven Psychopaths followed by arbitrage
followed by the gray nice then we got
end of watch and then perks of being a
wallflower I saw two of those movie
apparently they were very underrated and
another year reviewers exclusive
category is best hero because there are
a lot of heroes out there in movies
today and so we're gonna celebrate that
fact a lot of heroes in 2012 especially
and they start out with Batman from The
Dark Knight Rises James Bond from
Skyfall Django
from Django Unchained Iron Man from The
Avengers and The Incredible Hulk from
The Avengers
here are the Avengers to get a couple
and I'm just saying there were a few to
pick from and for every hero you need a
villain for him to fight so now we
celebrate the best villains of 2012
because there were some cool badasses
last year and the nominees are Tom Hardy
as Bane and The Dark Knight Rises javier
bardem from Skyfall Guy Pearce from
lawless Tom Hiddleston as Loki from The
Avengers and killing it off is Leonardo
DiCaprio as Calvin Candie in Django
Unchained so the next couple categories
are the breakthrough performances these
people may have been in a movie here and
there but 2012 was the year where
they're like hey by the way here we are
and we're here to probably stay I say
probably because if this was for 1999
Haley Joel Osment would probably win and
he's currently so the nominees for
breakthrough actress are Samantha barks
from Leigh miserab or lady Zara Bluth
for you people who are really gonna
nitpick Jennifer Lawrence for silver
linings playbook not not Katniss silver
linings playbook oh maybe you can stack
them and be like Lil Sis for 2012 here
two movies Keira Hayward and moonrise
kingdom rebel Wilson aka fat Amy and
pitch perfect and qua one second Wow qua
vans in a quote Vaughn's and a Wallis
that sounds about right Cole Evans and a
Wallis for beasts of the southern wild
so now the dudes need their shot these
are the breakthrough actors of 2012 and
they start out with Suraj Sharma in Life
of Pi Dane DeHaan in lawless and
chronicle Pierce Gagnon from looper
scoot mcnairy from Argo killing them
softly and Promised Land and Logan
Lerman from perks of being a wallflower
and now this was a much requested
category people were like why don't you
name the worst movie of the year so now
we have biggest stink pile of the year
that's that is clearly a Schmoe title
right there
aka biggest piece of if you're
on my channel whatever you want to call
it the worst thing that came out in 2012
and the nominees were
really for them are we start off with
Silent Hill revelation then we got a
thousand words then coming in after that
is that's my boy Adam Sandler it will
never cease to be on these lists
apparently they got resident evil
retribution and then piranhas three
double D or three D D or 3 D the next
category is a pretty fun category also
we've seen now the worst movie of the
year so now we're gonna go on to I'm
shocked it didn't suck these are the
movies where you see the trailer and
you're like that's probably not gonna be
good and then you see the movie and
you're like holy that was that was
good we start off with American Reunion
then we're going on to the grey then we
got dread and coming in next is Magic
Mike then we kill it off with 21 Jump
Street so the next category we got is
best soundtrack slash score I know
they're two different things but we just
integrate them into one why because
we're fun like that I'll say best music
so the nominees for best music are the
Hobbit and unexpected journey followed
by Django Unchained followed by Skyfall
then we got the Dark Knight Rises and
killing it off is lame is Iram a musical
is nominated for that category one would
think the next category in the category
of fun is best comedy Jew laughs in 2012
so did I a lot these are the reasons why
nominated for Best Comedy is silver
linings playbook followed by Seven
Psychopaths simile got cabin in the
woods I always saw it as a horror movie
but if you look at it more or less a
comedy and of course the two that had to
be in there are Ted followed by and
finishing the list 21 Jump Street so now
we're getting into the best performances
we got the best supporting actors and
actresses and chivalry is not dead while
I'm breathin we're gonna start off
ladies first starting off with Best
Supporting Actress of 2012 is Emily
Blunt from looper followed by Judi Dench
from Skyfall then we got Sally Field
from Lincoln then we got Amy Adams from
the master finishing it off is Anne
Hathaway aka Catwoman for the just
kiddin lame is our Rob and now the best
supporting actors of 2012 they are
javier bardem from Skyfall then we've
got Philip Seymour Hoffman from the
master gracing us with some
douchebaggery is Leonardo DiCaprio from
Django Unchained followed by Christoph
bolts from Django Unchained then killing
it off with Robert
Nero from silver linings playbook now
we're down to the lead performances my
friends Best Actress and best actor of
2012 these nominees are Jessica Chastain
from zero dark thirty Marion Cotillard
from rust and bone while Vaughn's and a
Wallace for beasts of the southern wild
did we got Naomi Watts from the
impossible and then Jennifer Lawrence
from silver linings playbook the chicks
are done let's see the Do's bring it for
the best actors of 2012 the nominees are
Denzel Washington from flight Joaquin
Phoenix from the master we got John
Hawkes from the sessions he was also in
Deadwood just sayin Bradley Cooper from
silver linings playbook and then killing
it off we got Daniel day-lewis from
Lincoln this next category goes without
saying without these people we wouldn't
have movies we got Best Director and the
nominees for 2012 are Kathryn Bigelow
for zero dark thirty
Joss Whedon for The Avengers David
O'Russell for silver linings playbook
Quentin Tarantino for Django Unchained
and Ben Affleck for Argo and never got
the category of categories the Best
Picture nominations for the third annual
year reviewers Movie Awards Best Picture
of 2012 the nominees are zero dark
thirty then we got moonrise kingdom then
cabin in the woods then we got looper
followed by The Avengers then we got
Django Unchained then we got silver
linings playbook
followed by Argo then we got Skyfall
killing off the entire list is the Dark
Knight Rises so there we are my friends
these are your nominations for the third
annual you reviewers movie awards will
get the award show to you in February
don't know the exact date yet I'll
collaborate with the schmoes will let
you know I'm gonna be on the schmoes
know podcast it'll ultimately be like a
little mini you reviewers thing it's
gonna have me the schmoes Chris Stockman
flick pick we'll all be on there talking
about the nominations for the you
reviewers Movie Awards I put a link
below two-toed hoc network we will be on
that show 8 p.m. Thursday night as 8
p.m. Pacific Standard Time otherwise
known as la time and we'll all be in the
studio together there and it should be
cool should be a lot of fun so what do
you think of the nominations guys let me
know who do you thinks gonna win this is
I'm telling you some of the nominees
surprised me I was surprised that some
things didn't get nominated curious for
your opinion my friends so calm
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more